here's the first thing you guys need to
know that Bren and I have a belly full
of sidecar doughnuts and Shake Shack
burgers feel sick bro yeah as do I see
this is the problem as I said to myself
not gonna eat junk today really but it's
my birthday come and come Saturday and
you guys surprise me and then with
sidecar doughnuts and Shake Shack well I
told am I supposed to not eat a burger
and I don't have to eat it and I told
cat just get the sidecar doughnuts but
then she came and one up to all of us
and brought the [ __ ] Shake Shack it's
delicious so I washed down a
cheeseburger and a doughnut and I feel
very sick my mother though was like I
said can I eat doughnuts
yes you know you people you asked your
mom today if you know like oh the other
day I go Canadiens Dylan I just what
just a rhetorical question goes yes the
guilt you people feel for eating one
doughnut is worse for you than [ __ ]
donut but I'll ask your mother give me
the donut the mommy I said mommy I mean
it all right this can i donut I put a
little dude I've been uh don't give me a
reason to celebrate how's it going shot
my special I've been on a strict diet
I'm just gonna let loose yeah so I've
been on my own or had my girls in
Chicago with my son so I'm all on my own
yeah so this is the third night in a row
I've ordered a large pepperoni pizza
from this New York place Wow they bring
the dough dough from New York it's
amazing freak you forget the name like
[ __ ] delicious third night in a row
I've eaten that whole pie by myself you
leave the whole pot by yourself the
whole large pie by myself and I'm never
been happier yeah ain't that and then I
wash it down with a one pint of ice
cream a pint of ice cream yeah I feel it
feel good after sometimes you can feel
good after you do that you know it's
time to stop though yeah it's time to
stop yes three well Sunday Monday
Tuesday that's three days yeah you'll do
two things one you'll binge on food and
the other is when you're when you'll you
need the smallest excuse to go by an
impossibly expensive pair of either
shoes or a jacket or car well car for
sure because that car's outrageous and I
need a truck so I'm looking at those you
need a truck now yeah
you got a tricked-out truck you can get
a man truck like a Ford
that'll be tricked out be a tricked-out
Ford Ford Raptor bro I like Joe Rogan's
cheap his Bronco yes I love that Bronco
they're not given that will go away
don't go you won right
they're not giving it away go get one my
mother goes free go get one of those I'd
have to put some money down
well they don't finance them so you have
to put all the cash down I got to put
all the cash I don't finance those they
don't know not those custom vehicles
that right there yep the icon yeah go
Dan made in Los Angeles California
mm-hmm fantastic truck amazing but we're
talking what give me a number
give me a number for you for me just for
you me like I wanna you yeah give me on
the basics I wonder what the Buffalo
leather like rhodium has inside got
Buffalo that yeah you don't want you
know what I like buffalo leather all
right let's just do regular leather for
you
maybe stingray in there I'd like a
little stingray a little Ray Ray and
then I throw it away in there little ray
man cool Hey portrays they have to get
eaten by killer whales seals sharks or
they're used for my truck or soup uh-huh
um you brought you you're looking about
200 grand minimum for that
200 grand guys so first you gotta buy
just a regular Bronco which is gonna be
you know yeah it's gonna be pretty
beat-up
yeah so you're gonna find one of those
they get it they get restore that
they're gonna put the icon touch on it I
would say out the door for you from
right down I mean average guy I don't
know for me and I want that one
you want all you want that one yeah with
the top up yeah 275 good because you
know because I love you
you might made mistaken I'm talking
about getting a restored Bronco the icon
correct I want the icon with them with
that with the Stingray Oh with all eyes
give me a regular and also there's no
hood so I should save money this to you
know just have a shirt no hood they're
like just like that dude I'm so sorry
man yeah with the canvas site in you
want stingray yeah and I'd like the
wheels like that but just there there
you go that that little thing right
there is just a trouble prom 300 grand
for that one I think that exact was what
pret to 7d to say there you go
$265
doesn't so that's the best you can do
for me it's best I can do man okay now
can you'd like well you know I'll do
like a social media post yeah oh cool
thanks there's no discount that's
amazing yeah and they sell yeah there's
a waitlist my man
there's a way oh you know what dude you
you know you should get why is a singer
Porsche bring that up chin dude that's
the car for you the singer Porsche yes
I'm down for that you can customize if
I'm excited now yes I can customize
everything dude really yes and I hope
you out you'll help me out for it all
right a singer that little thing no that
little thing dude big deal what is that
well what they do is that's an old 911
hold hold
yeah click on that one oh you want that
one I like what that green so check it
out what's funny what's funny about this
when we were talking with Porsches the
other day I saw that and I went chin
click on and he's already gone I got
Neverland on green I like that green and
I like that style and I want that ok
million 1.2 y-yeah 1.2 why'd your prom
with that I mean I want the regular
porch there that little porch I get out
they take the body of those old school
portions yeah and then just revamp
everything you pick out from the seat
belt color to everything this is for
freaks this is for crazy freaks and oh
boy when you want it you want you yeah I
don't like waiting for cars and whoa I
can give it to you in 2022 excuse me
your waiting list
what yeah Wow God can't have any car in
the world any guy can how people are in
car in the world it be a singer Porsche
you would yeah number over Ferrari just
McLaren's Bugattis it'd be what color
would it be I'm not mad at that green
you shouldn't be mad at that green it
blends in it's so understated and yet
you're driving a 1.2 million dollar car
well sir I did sure well look at the
inside of it don't work of all on
certain ones are a million they have
this that's not the million dollar they
have a million dollar one that's not it
but you're usually look at the end so
good God and you can pick everything
everything you want in there
get that it's all it's a work of art I
love that I like that that green I don't
like that some people look that's
ridiculous yeah ridiculously cool some
people don't like them because they just
feel like you know they're messing too
much with the vintage Porsche and it's
just you know buying the vintage Porsche
body and they've revamp it it's like on
steroids then we get a new car to your
exact detail goddamn so these are
separate companies from Porsche No
so these are these are off aftermarket
so they they take it's like AMG the
retailers nope Angie's part of Mercedes
it's like it'd be like what off-white
does for Nike mm so you know a contract
so in a contract but singer does it they
actually I think they're getting sued by
Porsche because they were taken off the
emblems the mortgage emblem and put on a
singer emblem of course like no no no
you can you can customize the [ __ ]
car
but you can't sell singers as singers
still bored Wow
so no you cannot how sick is that thing
yeah it's amazing it really is amazing
that's it that's it I get I get I love
craftsmanship so I love it in wine I
love it in cheese I love it in you know
anything like that and you see that
detail and you go well the reason I like
does cuz you're not gonna pull up next
to you know some agent in Hollywood that
has the same Porsche
yeah not going to you that's why I like
my car purple with the [ __ ]
houndstooth seach and I gonna pull up
someone that has that there's a guy I
know who sells so if you want to if you
have a house and you want it to be to
your specs and you want to use old
screws or whatever and he pulled out a
screw pull that a bolt of some kind with
a cool head on it and he goes that that
I sell this for you know five hundred
dollars and I went that's crazy because
is it try to find one go finally go I
went [ __ ] one over one of one I would
have talked yeah yeah yeah you don't use
what what is different and not everyone
can cookie cutter and go and buy you
know everything's like that it's always
like that
there was little details man you don't
[ __ ] fire it up to eight your
birthday want a sock you right in the
mouth but bring it to exile so I'll slip
that punch that's all I do now
today all I showed him your video knee
went tell him to stop did you say train
my boy cuz he's a fight enthusiast I did
I said can you train Brian count or Todd
Feldman he goes for you you know I do
I'll have him killed
whoa go Freddy no I think we're off on
this no nice no not kill both of us if
they ever attempt a box again what no
that's no I'm looking for it I already
see me move late now I showed him the
video
and he Freddy literally went like this
no no no Freddy please don't know I I
slit it but check out top Feldman's
jabbing it no I slipped left-right and
I'm very I'm always out of reach I'm not
being I'm not trying to be a dick I'm
always out of reach
I showed him Freddy said bring him in
here right now and I will not bolt them
out to the body I'll fight him and I put
on 16 inch clothes and I'll move around
with you 19 inch not familiar 6 inch I
mean 16 or 16 inch and I will that's a
porno all I might say is this and you're
a big strong guy do me a favor your
hands are up no problem
watch your midsection okay cool cool
cool man I don't like I'll tell you what
bothers me that you laugh a little bit
because I'd say what the boys out there
there and there grinding early yeah that
was there yeah I was there super early
you should go down okay so my boy Mario
Lopez sure now watch your P's and Q's
ready chomping at the bit to get ahold
of you chomping at the bit I hear he
actually I hate these later ox waiting
for you
AC Slater yeah gonna beat you up like
you're screech is that right they'll
[ __ ] you up like your screen how tall is
he tall don't worry about that yeah he's
in there bro how's he gonna get he lives
in there bro how's he gonna get past my
jack let's find out
I got a Viper quick jab yep let's find
out I got a why don't you keep your
stupid head on I double and triple up my
jab that's fine man but I want to see
him cuz I hear he can actually box got a
nice body on him - he said Marlatt I
hear he's sparse it's a muscular kid
that's a young Frank Grillo right there
uh yeah am I wrong no for sure is he as
big as Frank no no he's not biggest
Frank uh-huh but he boxes he's got he's
gotten in there
Duns from real boxing around Canelo hey
dude
well I'll say this video that if I had
to like let's say let's see this is the
movie Lionheart had to put money on it
yeah and they're fighting in wildcard
jim frank grillo or lopez yeah I get my
money up Frank that would make sense
Frank's a dog he's a dog like some
issues he has a [ __ ] he's hit that's a
dog
yeah I'm put my money on that dog with
some issues been heard and said you have
to be careful I have to be careful with
Frank because you know his he'll get
crazy you get crazy and want to get hit
gets hit he starts to fight let's see
this
Oh delahoy oh oh this is awesome
do you laughs do the hallways doing just
fine man listen nothing's better than
watching one of the best of all time
spar AC Slater oh you know what dude
it's for charity bro
by the way Lopes can move look at how I
love how I love how De La Hoya is just
[ __ ] with them I love it so much you
can just [ __ ] you look at that oh dude
he does whatever he wants huh although
although Lopes is being very respectful
isn't he well he has to Brian the same
thing how you pay your trainer gotta
keep it going
look at how [ __ ] there Delaware I can
touch his head anytime he wants yeah
that's the thing is obviously people
make a mockery of Australia you're
talking about the greatest of who makes
a mockery of that guy as a boxer one of
the great as human being now all right I
don't even do that
I got we don't I like him I love I just
love how he's probably weighs literally
50 pounds more than when he fought and
yet he'll beat your ass like riding a
bike dude yeah it's like riding a bike
you're also not touching him and he just
touches your face okay
catches them with hooks slow hook so
pace looks poop hate to watch this is
disgusting this is terrible you got a
right now [ __ ] Frank Gillis stop AC
Slater right now under under five rounds
I know it's got AC Slater Frank's Brahms
is Dutch of the dog yeah
so that that's a very strange oh here we
go here we go definitely show me against
a prime Canelo like they're actually
working like teaching them dude you know
you know what Freddie Roach told me
though and the interviews come out
hopefully showtime doesn't care you know
Aaron Pico the kid who fights this
Saturday shirt know you're in Pecos
right I've been watching since he was 16
so you know Freddie's had him since he
was young I didn't know only guys
Freddie trains and is Freddie I go how
good is he he goes he'd be world
champion boxer right now oh it really
goes well he was Miguel Cotto's only
training partner for a long time when
are you [ __ ] me this as a as a
teenager he was his main training
partner and he goes and I went well
Cotto is just like working with music
oh no he would win rounds from Miguel
Cotto when it was Miguel Cotto
that's [ __ ] my way get the [ __ ] out
of here swear to God he was that kid he
was I asked him when can you do boxing
he was been so focused on MMA use he'd
be a world champion next month if you
wanted to
well I remember him he had been boxing I
remember and wrestling from started
boxing first and then went to rest in
his rest and then before then for went
College just to pursue professional
because it's 16 17 he was fighting he
was wrestling in international
tournaments he's the number one in the
world number one in the United States
what u.s. [ __ ] what a product we'll
think about the product to be for a
Freddie Roach from the output time India
goddamn it's insane it is insane
frequent a total freak I mean just I
mean he's stupid he's stupid all these
dudes his body I mean this is he's gonna
be that good young guys stooop how old
is he here's my question what I need to
know here's my question if you had to
put money on it with money on it because
he's been fighting so long like by the
time he's 30 sometimes that can be like
retirement age because you've been
fighting so long really
right everyone that you know that you
like in boxing started that young you're
really you're referring to MMA guys yes
who start young so they have no other so
they start older because they have no
other option right boxing and the
greatest boxer when they were very young
can all start when he was
seven yeah six yeah
Miguel co-starred when he's for Floyd
Mayweather grew up box you know the
great start when their kids met thank
you
it's not a sport to learn when you're
older Freddie talks about that too in
the interview he's like he started he
started boxing when he's a kid which is
rare so much for a mixed martial artist
he's complete freak meant it's gonna be
cool to sleep freak we're doing a fight
campaign you're gonna I'm gonna try to
make it why was he not why did he not go
right into the UFC more money would what
why didn't Aaron Pico why did he choose
Bellator over us they had no fights why
would you go right to the UFC look what
happens when you go right to the UFC
yeah you go to Bellator cuz they they
they do it right and then later on you
go over to the USA or not or you stay in
Bellator and make tons of more money
like a lot of guys are doing uh-huh the
UFC is not the answer for prospect if
you're a young prospect you only go
there you they're gonna throw you to the
Wolves take every all the money that
came out here and then back up
our bad he's do 45 correct 45 M 55 but
you have 45 s is home I feel sick did
feel sick no I had half I was shooting
today dude shooting was great this is
the last week yes this is the last week
it's been a lot it's just been a long
days because right now they seem to be
changing the script on a daily basis
what happens is they go we're shooting
these new pages that's okay there you go
and we all go what and the schedule
changes and you hit me up like dude
can't do the podcast today you're also
there for 19 hours if you're certain
people if your crew or whatever you're
there 19 hours they compensate for that
huh the yes yet well but it's just a lot
you know you're there all the time and
so most people drive two hours to get to
work
geez yeah yeah the the finest working
people that I know and I'm not kidding
that just some all-around best people
are the crew that work behind the scenes
they're so [ __ ] professional you will
know if you work in the Hollywood Union
if you're a guy who works crew your
camera I bet you none of those people
have ever been late for win one but I
bet none of them in
one minute not one minute here in their
life no in their life Kenny one that you
ain't driving not an activity around
right you wouldn't be wrong it's like
the military they are just never late
never and they're never they never [ __ ]
up in 13 episodes of this show not one
person on my crew oh and if they have I
haven't seen not one person is [ __ ] up
even a little cuz well you got to show
up with like you got everything's got a
match
everything's got a match your hair's got
to look a certain way you gotta sit
where the same your collar has to be
folded the same way for every shot
because they might do a reshoot you do a
reshoot you got it
they never [ __ ] up they never [ __ ] up I
don't know how they do it nobody forgets
anything it's good oh you do you stained
your shirt 16 times we got a seventeenth
shirt yep it's I can never do that job I
am amazing not built for that job
yeah your thing yeah professional
professors become a director do that new
director forget it that's the night but
sometimes even like hair those those top
hairstylist
so I don't when Jessica Simpson had a
hair stylist flown in I talked to him I
said she flew you in from New York he
goes yeah I said you're the best time he
goes oh I don't know and I said and
somebody goes he's the best
I said why she's well he'll make her
hair a certain kind of blond that you
won't know why but it stands out it just
is better than everybody else there's a
guy who were works out a box woman with
Tony and he's the number one male
hairdresser in the United States but
he's not from here for your reads from
and great guy looks identical to Tom
Brady he's married to a famous actress I
forget his name great dude I think he's
French
hmm and Tony was telling me how much
charge for hair come like what the [ __ ]
he owes well no he worked with everybody
probably just those guys good but I take
my I'll take my half and I'll see him I
just like wait am I here just I want to
see him be like dude all you should do
this it's details it's the [ __ ]
details who cuts your hair cuz this girl
named Colleen you been going there for a
while yeah ever since I've been in LA I
met her through the girl who used to dye
my hair they're tough to find right like
again yes sir the [ __ ] your [ __ ] I
there's a guy was super super expensive
that my wife was trying to get me to go
to like four dollars well okay you still
do off Main Street yeah they're not mean
a bikini a bikini yeah yeah it looks
like you blew it
yeah $500 that's right you always look
exactly this yeah but I never chart paid
that much but no I'm just saying like
that if you paid anything well this guy
who charts for nossek us come and see me
and he was working on a show I was doing
and I went what would you do with my
hair and he goes magic what's gonna
happen dude I'm gonna you're gonna go
Brys what if he didn't lies you're
really good-looking dude so you know the
way the way I do it I go to the Lincoln
barber's off Lincoln and clearly and
it's all Mexican dudes in there right
yeah and when you go in there it's a
crapshoot because you just walk in
there's 18 [ __ ] barbers my boy what is
this new dude he came from New York he's
this Porto Rican dude long here speaks
zero English really zero and he is the
[ __ ] man I've only worked with him
twice mm-hmm and I saw he was working
with some day I'm like god I hope he
[ __ ] gets finished with that guy
sorry I'm jumping with him then there's
a girl who no offence probably the worst
I'm like don't give me her you can't
insult them right now I'm good you
should go is that all they do is go next
there's no no appointment nothing next
so it's our race I'm sweating and the
Puerto Rican goes hmm he's because like
this thing I was like [ __ ] yeah bro
[ __ ] right well I feel like I've
signed that hard to cut right did well
she doesn't understand English shot that
song come over and translate it for him
it's not that hard they have to fade
it's all about the fade it's an art bro
I can fade your hair up Oh
Terry's baby sadder would like older
man's age it's like whoa my problem or
like a complete [ __ ] dude all of that
problem all that as you get older is
like getting fades dressing a little too
cool in even TRT as far as I'm concerned
there I said it
well what's funny is uh Mike Epps I was
I think I was on Instagram
he had this video because he was Jordans
all the time and he has a legit argument
like he's in Georgia jerseys and people
are roasting them and he goes you little
[ __ ] we're the ones that made
Jordans cool
stop wearing them he's like I've been
wearing these since the [ __ ] yeah
late 80s and now you guys think they're
all cool and now I can't wear them cuz
you [ __ ] just jumped on this
you don't even seen the dude play it's
not true and you gonna stop we're these
cuz y'all makin my car gotta fit in with
the young guys right it's true that guys
that's good these guys aren't that old
though they just have gray hair mm yeah
that guy's very young died piece yeah
mmm yes the biggest nose yeah these guys
with their beards
why is it that certain places like
Portland stuff they all have the lawyers
and tattoos what is that see that dude
looks pretty [ __ ] dope I wish my hair
was like that I'd love to have hair like
that but I don't have that kind of hair
no for you
I would I look forward to being a silky
box and any other style absolutely
besides shaving and that gets it I mean
besides shaving your your head yeah
there's another study could do you would
know exactly right like this there's
nothing
let's get you wigs you would've loved we
did you were to love me the other day
I'm I walking to Blue Bottle coffee and
I'm with my buddy Joey and I see eight
fifteen hundred dollars worth of caviar
yesterday cool and I back to this I
didn't pay for it I walk on my buddy Joe
and I look I see this guy was 6-3 about
235 blond and he and I and I look at his
shorts he's got shorts the kind of
Schwartz I wear on the Goldbergs sure -
right but more expensive and designer
and I went and I stopped I went well
look at that guy's legs yeah it's the
craziest things I've ever seen in my
life
yeah the craziest legs I've ever seen
sure go what does that guy do and you
know your boy I walk on my go bro okay
let's take your dick what do you do for
your legs because I played it I was that
well you know I'm a Viking I guess and
when I started lifting weights my body
just took to it I go what will you an
athlete he goes I played a Texas AI
ma'am I was a tight end uh and he behind
Marcus Bennett works yeah he said so I
only played my senior year he goes yeah
it was bad Marcus Bennett so I sat the
bench but then I played my see a really
cool guy after trades people at Barry's
boot camp
see if you can see Barry's bootcamp
Venice there's a ton of berries
boot camps right now is that a good if
you you've done that right I've never
done berries I've heard of it I've never
done it though I like orange thery I've
never done berries though I'm sure it's
good I would be down to do it how about
berries I was looking for a picture of
this dude I'm bearish yeah I was
laughing I was like well I'm did you get
a picture or something you bring it up
here fellas I'm no I'm trying to find
his name but whatever yeah good looking
dude yeah well I was just it was very
humorous to me because he was he was so
striking that everyone in the coffee
shop was looking at him or just you well
there is one other one there he is there
he is terrible picture ah you're kidding
terrible picture of them ah you're
kidding that's a terrible picture of a
terrible picture on the right is that
really that's him oh hey Brian Hey look
at me and Ruki yeah hold on let me talk
to you you're gonna meet him and you're
gonna shut it up let me just talk to you
yeah don't care wait hon you're fearful
what'd you say about my boyfriend cuz I
used to be straight I'm no longer
straight I know I know you're not okay I
want you to come out the age of 52 as a
gay man I'm not doing that unless Dan
Drew and this Android's says there's my
- impressive about this guy Bobby's a
little twist me Baba please he's ever
been as big as you you have to
understand his legs are bigger than
yours his legs
scoff at yours hey let me tell you this
his legs hey you don't know you're a gay
older man dude I'm just telling you hey
have you you've ever done
have I ever chin can I ever came in here
and told us regularly Google no please
don't
about a story about a man that I saw in
a coffee shop that's the point I good he
was I stopped him as a I stopped he got
I go I go I stopped him and I was like
it was so gay of me and you would have
been see what his role here I would much
more eat him up I need better picture
listo do it do it right now you need to
calm down because this is gonna what are
we gonna do we're gonna see this guy go
cool Brian good lookin dude assault a
copy song sure talk to him better
pictures better picture bad picture I
can't tell well there is pictures not
good pictures
for the dude bright ran to the coffee
shop there you go the instructors I
gotta go take some classes the point I'm
making
well hey out now wow I gotta talk to him
Wow I know I would just have a talk with
yourself about about my about my gayness
about my terrible game in heaven are you
homophobic dude no I'm not I just find
it crazy you just told me a story about
this dude you ran to a car I told you
because listen ask him if it's a
ridiculous hot girl 3 tomorrow even my
buddy do I enjoy it with my buddy chosen
are you gonna ask him about his like
psycho I am I don't get it I just I
don't understand I'm spilt there cuz I
want I feel different I mean not into
men it's so clarity I want to be I want
to be I want to look like that now I
sure I get it here's the thing doughnut
shop
bet a million dollars that a dick has
never touched Brian's mouth I could not
make that got into your head cut your
head and do it for the guy that's like
Neverland oh let's not
he's too into dude this I don't know
what you're talking about but it's not a
big deal bro not you obviously it is and
obviously you're ridiculing me just
because I appreciate masculine
pulchritude let's go to current events I
don't know I guess I guess you want to
talk about boyfriend of bears book all
right yep by the way I don't know how
many people look at me like when I'm I
come to your show or whatever and like
it's a fighter and kid event I just how
many guys like the big gay al over and
over on my gosh [ __ ] you've earned that
bro I sure have there's nothing wrong
with that Taiwan bikini hiker freezes to
death after long intervening on solo
climb yeah so there's a 60 no 36 my mom
a 36 year old woman who is known for
going on these hikes in China and her
name is Gigi she was once I guess her
friend bet her to go and dress up in a
bikini and while she's doing her hike
and take a photo what's wrong it went
viral that in her small like community
okay and so she started doing that as a
trend on her Instagram page and recently
she went on a hike even though there was
really bad weather conditions and yeah
grim yeah she ended up falling into a
ravine and rescuers were unable to get a
helicopter to her in time and so she
died could they throw blankets down
there she's brown conscious the Lin said
the top rescue team hiked for 28 hours
to reach the body only sleeping for
three hours because they knew the
temperatures were rapidly plunging [ __ ]
man she fell 3,000 meters yeah after she
fell she was still alive and she was
able to get hold of her satellite cell
phone is how they described it she
called her friends and let them know
that she accidentally fell but she
couldn't feel her the lower half of her
body
rescuers went and sent a team to go hike
up the mountain since they couldn't get
any helicopters there to her and she
ended up dying see is that the only
picture we have of her don't hike alone
and don't dive alone damn she [ __ ]
climbed a hundred Peaks so she must've
been in shape yeah right that's it
though that those are there I'm sure we
get following answers hey man I have no
interest a bikini climber you know what
they call Alpine hiking like when you
climb Mount Everest they call it the art
of suffering
no thank you you will get cold you will
get hungry you will I guess that was her
thing huh
yeah just bikinis it gets freezing up
there as she learned
yeah the hard way you got to respect
mother nature I think she respected it
she just their mountains you know so
[ __ ] happens like a big just to win and
your small Asian lady that's right sir
that's Colonel she taking a selfie that
which is why you might want to hike with
a partner somebody who's there she only
go alone Kat it doesn't specify I don't
know whether she was alone on this
particular one but didn't seem like
there was anyone with her bummer
well you said up to her family yeah what
else you got she froze to death
sometimes when you hike and when you're
hunting things like doll sheep which are
very
very tasty lothario I live there like
that look how about doll sheep but
they're really hard to talk because they
can they can see you a mile away like
they can smell you from FRA taste goats
yes the apparently incredible tasting so
you want to kill them I don't but but
there are such a prized possession and
in order to hunt them
you have to hike up the most insane
cliffs they live on the top tippy top of
everything okay
that's where campaigns boy died Wow be
sure they were hunting those sheep on
the on the side of the mountain is boy
fell off there you go and a lot of times
you'll shoot a dollar sheep and you
can't get to it
cuz it'll fall down a thing so you have
to be careful where you shoot it it's a
[ __ ] dude those sheep that climb the
side of mountains are insane they're
incredible
those you've seen those sheep that was
on an um what do you call those slant
earth who are I'd like to [ __ ] just
the ones on the dams the sheet of the
[ __ ] raw there's like this much room
and there's pounce that's nuts
what a weird life yeah and even the baby
ones [ __ ] with it
because they follow the mom and they can
still do it it's just they have
ingrained in them look at that you know
what I don't become when if I get if I
die come back wreak coronated I don't
wanna become that sheet now that'd be
that's what they do there that I haven't
seen this really no no just a shield
there look in the salt on the there on
the the dam the side of the Daisy super
super look at them nowhere to go they
are a terrible life one fault game over
yeah Wow so when Eagles come and get
them I don't know if you see they pick
him up and drop him they do look at the
little babies even they're like yeah
they could get we rock climbing baby
right out the womb we brought Eagles
just come along it's very cool
yes definitely I want to be that when
they come back on this earth yeah I
don't want to shoot a doll sheep I don't
want to do that up there I'd it is
delicious though it would be real shitty
I'd rather be that sheep that climbs the
side of the mountain than me the Sheep
who gets [ __ ] by his owner that
happens to some sheep well it does
happen in some Middle Eastern I don't
know if it's Middle East I think it's uh
it's places like Ireland anywhere
there's [ __ ] all Middle East for sure
bro
I don't know anywhere they
user there's video the end we talked to
soldiers a lot of times on the on the
[ __ ] heat cameras like the night
vision they'd be scanning they could see
the that's where is it in Liberia where
they they were [ __ ] donkeys or no is
in let's ride raw hanim are somewhere in
that a [ __ ] donkey yeah there's a lot
of donkey [ __ ] and one vice to the
thing on it vice did a whole thing
don't you saw it donkey sex their most
burrs yeah hard tradition yep hit that
yep they bang donkeys because they
because it you call it without talking
about the women call donkey a jackass
[Music]
men will do some weird things yeah it
seems like it's just people talking
about it alright sure we see this guy
time at who Martin's are gonna [ __ ] you
saying I've been for use listening oh
she said I've been with a rough estimate
a 100 donkeys we were kids a good friend
of mine said Martin come let's go [ __ ] a
donkey it was the first time I was going
to [ __ ] a donkey
he said come on you go first I said wait
a second how does this go he said just
go up to it pull it open pull them and
solve this donkey's pink [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] a lot of times you think about a
girl sure or a donkey and sometimes just
there buster nuts and donkeys donkey
[ __ ] dude this is fast it's right
there you know humans are a lot more
complicated yeah no [ __ ] doc had sex
with you know dogs that female dogs are
a lot tighter oh my god they say you
know I
so you had sex with a female dog you
don't want to have sex with a woman
anymore
my ass is freaking cream after my wife
caught me three months later I was back
from a job on the countryside saw this
finance donkey and I saw a donkey a
pregnant donkey with a nice fat ass he
says big ass I pulled over got off my
bike went out to her and took her behind
the bush what they call zoophilia
somebody maybe completely straight and I
would assume that the wife is like am I
gonna catch something or yeah see betty
has a [ __ ] high thought for a dick
yeah because the street donkeys that you
find are getting [ __ ] first by one guy
a lot of times I'm to turn on my god and
[ __ ] them without the condom or anything
dude this guy didn't give a [ __ ] about
cameras that's impressive right there
big-ass giant erection in this [ __ ] yeah
that donkeys like wait what are we doing
Martinez back there preparing the [ __ ]
the donkey Tobey Maguire his mouth is
the deepest thing that you ever seen oh
they're gonna film a mountain er look at
him it's like the surprise you knew was
coming and you didn't want to be there
oh my god all right well he's probably
got a donkey dick so what we're watching
is a dude [ __ ] in a donkey oh wow
he's he pulls his shirt up and then he's
just donkey sees he's just fine [ __ ]
this donkey he's got a cigarette mr.
cocky cocky doesn't give a [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is like oh look now he's
rubbing the donkey just busted in the
donkey now he's rubbing the donkey's ass
I get why you'd be bummed that's what
the guy likes to do you [ __ ] well
oh wow wow nice guys but they didn't
wash the stick on that bag he's walking
this way watch his dick off in that poor
there's crocodiles in that stale pond
roughly Crocs in it up in any tidy
package because it doesn't exist
Oh putting the Mundy's on he just Darst
dude I'm telling you as a giant tell me
is that good good after you can tell Oh
but also he washed his dick off in that
dirty pond do but that's the least a
green poly I've seen it all way too damn
Wow dude I had no idea
yeah I had no idea aren't something when
you do fight undecayed buddy yeah Stan
you learn something when you do it with
me cuz I'll come up here and there you
pop one often that's right you pop one
off
don't say pop one off I'll pop one on
you don't say pop one all now don't say
why cuz I just outed myself as a gay man
about donkey [ __ ] hmm I don't know
you start another did you guys know
about zoophilia does he feel they have
people yeah I mean I do mr. hand see
that's where you're messing with fire
when you're letting the animal [ __ ] you
messing with fire dude correct
that's dangerous super ask mr. hands I
think people let their dogs [ __ ] I
believe that happened
girls right well and guys I'm John yeah
they're done how did the dog to know
well they don't but did they'll hump
yeah they helped your leg all the time
yeah they just won't even get a dog that
you can get him gone what I don't know
man you can really small male dog to
small but I imagine you got a big enough
dog oh yeah I know I know that why is so
open about [ __ ] Dalton did not give a
didn't know this you can be broadcast to
the world over 12 million people I've
seen that videos a calf [ __ ] donkeys
over a hundred matter of fact he's kinda
home and [ __ ] my wife big deal then I'm
gonna wash my dick in this leech
infested water yeah on my way home in
this puddle in a puddle stagnant in a
bottle mud puddle we're crocodiles yeah
Owen are there any Emmy
but what if that guy just has stripes
all over his dick
we don't know I feel like he's just
crazy yeah I think it's mentally I think
he's a guy yes
do you know this do you know so one of
the things I know is that maybe growing
up overseas and in many countries where
there were a lot of herders of animals
but you would always hear these rumors
for real that Shepherds because they
spent so much time alone out there
we're always a little crazy they were
always a little off and they think about
it in the Sheep yeah you're a guy alone
out there with your goats your sheep
under skin a costume bro
yeah definite function them you're the
only guy out there you're on the only
guy out there on the mountain let's
snuggle up with them sure your remote
you're out there there are no women it
did it was always there always these
rumors about me what's the most [ __ ]
animal donkeys are sheep I think it's
sheep more people that [ __ ] around
with sheep then yeah maybe cows that
would imagine no way people [ __ ] cows
sure jinn look you need to Stalin and
right that the most no just put human
[ __ ] cow well let's see I don't think
so bro now the cows are so big and
awkward yeah but you need to get up
ahead of chauffeuring what about horses
wait let me go ahead there's a lot of
horse [ __ ] probably only because to
total to me and if they don't like it
game old you're getting kicked and you
died yeah but I just feel like like
doctor you're just porns human [ __ ] ow
no cow freeze of fury of videos yeah
we're don't click on these costumes
what about images human cow slaves well
that's just a dude dressed up oh my god
okay this is dong in his mouth well yes
because the Jersey cows probably a baby
and suckling on what it thinks is an
otter goddamnit
damn it what is why why do I I wouldn't
brought children in this world this
whole [ __ ]
the world is a mess it's a mess you know
that why is that guy letting us know no
dude I'm just scroll down to okay what
is this episode we're doing at the photo
why are we even talking about this stuff
house is not too much huh this I had no
idea people were doing this with cows
yeah human beings have been banging cows
forever of course they have of course
they have yes too much human beings do
whatever they can they did that human
beings are we're just Apes
we're just perverted Apes you know
anything you get my mother you saw say
anything you can think of has been done
anything you can think of has been done
to another person or a person is done so
I don't know I for the first life I
haven't speechless yeah Jersey cow two
cows outside house a lot of people
around cows anytime anybody's around an
animal I I just don't I
okay I do not know this yeah what Scott
Lee let poor Jersey cow it says how to
rape a cow there that's all
instructional for Christ's sake that's
several but I mean but the human being
is layered there we go weird okay let me
clear this oh yeah get that off our
search history it's more signed into
this thing uh yes this is perfect time
to hide okay so yesterday a article came
out saying that Chris Brown was arrested
in Paris because a woman accused him as
well as his friend and bodyguard of
raping her and shortly after he made
bail he came out on social media and
said that she's lying and there was a
woman who came out on her Instagram as
well posting a video of the article
saying that it was a lie and people
assumed that she was the one who accused
Chris Brown of raping her along with his
friends but she said that she was
actually there at the after party where
the events took place and that she said
that nothing happened basically what's
crazy about him is obviously with his
history when as soon as you see this
everyone just [ __ ]
right everyone just you and I saw Mike
[ __ ] Chris Brown man what a [ __ ]
but you know this day and age who knows
he's now suing her for defamation which
makes sense
yummy half to that that's the only way
you're gonna quit these people with
these accusations and making these fake
me to movement claims and stuff yeah
let's just start [ __ ] suing people
well they can't have it you just can't
have you do cuz it ruins you know you've
just ruined your time I would say that
these kind of actors are very rare you
know these most women are probably
telling the truth yeah I agree I think
you know unless they're super famous
like this
some of you can get little sketchy yes
and then when you're super famous you
better watch what you're doing the other
thing is with a guy with his history is
it that crazy to think that you maybe
it's a little muddy there the only thing
I would say is that so so if a woman
came forward and asked for money if she
tried to extort him I'd be like she's
asking for money yeah I agree but this
woman's just coming forward period right
like she's just saying it what's she
getting out of it I know is she gay you
know I'm saying is she trying to settle
out of court
like so so if this woman settles out of
court and it goes away she's 29 now I'm
skeptical if she doesn't then I'm gonna
be a 24 year old malos at around 4 a.m.
local time they decided to leave the
club one of Brown's friends allegedly
grabbed her by the arm
and convinced her to go back to the
hotel with them and another guy I
believe all right
karema claimed that back at the hotel
Brown's bodyguard allegedly took
everyone's cell phone I believe awesome
meaning it you know once in the room she
was offered a drink claims she noticed
drugs in the room okay that's he's a
rock star she also said that there were
more than a dozen other people in the
hotel room okay fantastic it's a party
at one point during the night karema
said she went to the bathroom and Brown
allegedly father grabbed her arm and
pulled her into the room resembling a
closet she told the tabloid that the
alleged assault went on for nearly 30
minutes
karema then alleged that she was raped
by one of Brown's friends and his
bodyguards in the bedroom she told
closer that she was able to get her
phone back and left the room in tears
fallen ones allegations Brown two others
body got retained in Paris okay he
denied allegations alright so here's my
question
did she go to the police and did she get
and collect evidence that has not been
disclosed yet well so CBS could not
verify the allegation the first thing
that CBS is gonna ask is do you have
proof is there a rape kit because police
officers and I can promise you in Paris
they have this police officers know
exactly what to do in this situation you
go I got really well the reason now the
reason so CBS said they couldn't verify
it if you can't verify it it means there
was no rape kit and no now well that's
maybe they could have verify at the time
of the story right meaning the French
police or the Paris police didn't offer
that information right they just got the
story posted so we can't verify right so
if you go to the police and they have
the DNA a three to eight men yeah it
doesn't necessarily mean you're gonna
win a rape case because those guys could
say it was consensual right Lester's but
we're not hearing Chris Brown say it was
consensual we're just saying it was
complete this is false and a whole lot
of crap I wanna make I heard a person
say as they go dude famous rap to forget
his name the they go dude Chris Brown at
any show can pull six hundred girls out
of that crowd and [ __ ] all of them not
but that that defense doesn't work here
because if you're Chris Brown and that's
you you have your that your mo of
hurting women you've hit women you've
awfully beat up women you sound that
twice right yes twice even as other ex
as that so if that's what you do it's
not it's not fun for him just to pull
out these girls who will [ __ ] him or
suck him off at the show it's awfully a
personality trait that he's attracted
dominating women hitting them making
them feel less in fury or he or he or he
has ten you know sickness tempers that
then he flies off and starts hitting
girls yeah
either way it's a character true yeah
this isn't something we're like oh he'll
learn from mistakes I know that's not
you don't learn from that right yeah man
and by the way some nice somebody might
have been so distraught that she didn't
go to the police because she was just so
[ __ ] up south a lot of times are
scared
again but until we get more info I'm not
ready to hang the guy out to dry yet but
with his background well we'll say that
they ended up releasing him on bail with
no restrictions from leaving pick the
country oh so they're saying that it's a
pretty good sign that there isn't very
solid evidence there's nothing right
yeah cuz they let him go back to the
States
Oh in that case there's no evidence have
no evidence yeah yeah so it could just
and again there's a ton of crazy girls
out there we're like Chris Brown is a
horrible background [ __ ] this dude let's
get some money out of them do they do
this and then Chris like what the [ __ ]
man right I don't know she's just there
it's a weird it's a weird thing with his
background when you ever this comes out
you kind of like because I can
definitely see it I've seen the Rihanna
pictures so I've definitely seen it yeah
yeah but this doesn't look like maybe
didn't do it man the thing is that you
did that's why we have something called
innocent until proven guilty you've got
a you have to present evidence if
there's no evidence and and if they let
him go home then and I by the way
remember that I believe France has no
extradition treaty with the United
States meaning if Chris Brown gets
convicted of something in France I don't
believe he has to go back to Paris and
vice versa
Roman Polanski when he was convicted of
raping and sodomizing and drugging a 13
year old went to Paris and lived in
Paris and knew that he was safe there
and has been since so you know I don't
know man I don't know it's interesting I
have to believe that the police let him
go there was no evidence agree
Jim the benefit of the doubt may have
great style that give him that and also
the best dancer of our generation he's a
hell of a dancer so talented yeah it's
women yeah so do you guys remember the
fire festival I'm gonna watch the
documentary on Netflix though rather you
remember shut up about it last night do
you remember what the festival was and
the outcome yes yep so there was a
documentary that came out recently on
Netflix explaining what happened and how
basically the guy who started it is
basically the biggest con man within
that team and
oh when the documentary came out there
was a clip of a woman who worked there
and she basically was in charge of
feeding everyone at the festival and she
didn't have enough workers or supplies
to facilitate feeding everyone just
because it was planned so poorly know
what they're doing
yeah and so when the creators of fire
festival left the island they ended up
leaving her as well as other workers who
were in charge of certain areas like
construction or cooking with the bill
and so their workers came to them
demanding money so she used $50,000 from
her savings to pay everyone know worked
under her off in the last clip is her
crying saying that she she doesn't wanna
talk about fire festival anymore because
it just brings so much pain ja Rule
ended up getting a bunch of tweets after
this documentary came out people were
very angry at him and he said that he
didn't do this festival out of malicious
intent to scam anybody and that he felt
really bad for that woman he the other
guy got six eight years but he hasn't as
he's seen any he's not seeing any time
right as of right now no she so they did
a GoFundMe and it raised up $160,000
which is more than she's good however
she says like if ja Rule was really
sorry that he would donate a hundred
thousand or just take your hundred sixty
and shut the [ __ ] up right paid fifty
mm-hmm come on yeah ja Rule could send a
tweet I'll be like my bad had no idea
girl so he had to pay for that
Oh GoFundMe hundred sixty you good could
do that but IIIi don't know what Ja
Rule's doing finance does he have the
money to do that
is he ballin like I don't know what he's
doing is he made smart investment well
you and I know that a hundred grand for
a lot of people in Hollywood is a
shitload of money you'd be surprised how
many people don't have that saved up a
hundred gasps hello to my friend when
Bronstein does ja Rule have 100 grand to
spare I'm Sam he's at some huge you said
no I wouldn't these were all like if
this is P Diddy we know P Diddy's
richest [ __ ] give her a hundred grand ja
rule I don't know dude I could quit a
good point I would I would say he
doesn't agree with me and some jams bro
Diddy oh yeah
rulz murder and he's all tiny he's tiny
yes oh yeah pretty sure he's like Kevin
Hart sighs no really true oh you will me
burn uh so take off two inches there by
seven DMX's what else we got eleven
definitely not so so do you know who
bebe Rexha is I don't
so she's a she's a jam out though right
yeah bring up one her songs reach in so
that's hurts mmm that's her she's sexy
as hell wouldn't be too late she just
got nominated for two Grammys and she
ended up or chance her team asking them
to reach out to other designers to see
if they want to dress her for the award
show and a lot of them actually turned
her down because she's a size eight girl
yeah Harvey but big kid let me see her
play play a video for us she says she's
a size oh she's the one who sings uh she
looks sad I'm not mad at her at all not
many of it I'm trying to see the body
though what I've only heard this song a
thousand times and I mean in every other
song go back to go to another stuff
she's got a go go to that one she's in a
it's just beautiful
I don't know looks then she don't look
big well say six times eight isn't very
big actually
is it not a zit curvy dude she's like
I'm a size six you're tiny yeah and so
the Hollywood want size zero or ones
under sin they're just saying that she's
too big for them to want to dress like
too curvy yeah oh she is curvy there you
go why Prime have big fellow issues
either do I celebrate this bill damn
right you do how do you what I can you
go to Enrique for a bride where's your
sighting nothing nothing what what were
you saying but she made an Instagram
video about it that went viral shoes
piss yes
an outfit yeah and then she well [ __ ]
your dresses she's gotta wear mommy's
she's so cute I mean come on so I
finally get nominated at the Grammys and
it's like the coolest thing ever and a
lot of times artists will go and talk to
designers and they'll make them custom
dresses to walk the red carpet you judge
so I have my team head out a lot of
designers and a lot of them do not want
to dress me because I'm too big
literally like I'm too big and if a size
six eight is too big then I don't know
what to tell you then I don't want to
wear your [ __ ] dresses because that's
crazy cuz all you're saying that all the
women in the world that are sizing it up
are not beautiful and they cannot wear
your dresses so all so all the people
that said it now I'm thinking I can't
wear dresses [ __ ] you I don't want to
wear your [ __ ] dresses ain't gonna
name them I wonder how many turned her
down though I'm not sure but I remember
there was a story about the same thing
happening to Melissa McCarthy yeah same
thing happening to Leslie Jones as well
hi Meryl is Lee Jones those Jones a big
girl therefore less Jones is tall mm-hmm
you're just surprised because B Rex is a
very small girl my size 8s still going
to the Grammys yes she's not big I want
it but also in this current culture I
wonder if these designers really turned
her down like she's too thick they know
they're gonna get back and I'll said by
what if one was like why won't she
wanted us particular dress and the
designers like where that's all we got
it's just a sigh see that's what I feel
like I feel like she's get this
information from her people and there's
nothing worse because what happens is
it's a game of telephone in this
business 1000 times so I went and I had
to do this I gave Todd Phillips a speech
after he won the hangover like best in
Montreal apparently so this is what Todd
said though so I get a call I got a call
on this like Brian hey Todd Phil's to be
so honored for you to fly first-class to
stay in his hotel and come make a speech
for him because he's being awarded best
comedy director at the Just for Laughs
comedy festival in Toronto like our
Montreal big big thing and they
make this huge thing about they have an
itinerary and he's he's really excited
and everything else I called Todd and
this is like a wheelie I go what do you
want me to say about you he goes for
what I go for the thing in Montreal he
goes what thing in Montreal I go you
you're being awarded Best Director he
goes aw yeah I got gonna do that thing I
go he goes what about it I go well you
asked for me to be to make a speech for
you then he goes you're doing that and I
go yeah you you see you asked for me
specifically he goes I did not because
all I said when my assistant said do you
want something invented to kind of bring
you up and I was tying my shoe and I
said if Callens doing stand-up of there
I guess he could do it that's what he
said
it became the biggest [ __ ] thing and
I believe they gave me money for
anything I got paid like five grand as
well yeah it was a great [ __ ] weekend
but it was like no it was like one dude
says one thing and believe me in
Hollywood
everybody wants yeah everybody wants to
with daddle this fight it felt like a
knockdown yeah [ __ ] those [ __ ] they
they would they're probably being caddy
with each other somebody was a jerk or
maybe her a sister man or someone she
was like I don't want this designer yeah
I'm designer is like dude we're all out
of that sighs yes she's got like you you
won't believe this they don't have size
eight and she's like oh he'll marry go
and then I'll guess what's gonna happen
some big-time designers are like oh
that's [ __ ] up there make a custom
dress she's a little gorgeous this will
all be every designer now it's gonna
have their hands up corner we didn't say
that
I'll make your address right some
designers gonna save the day like Gucci
or someone and they're just shouldn't
come along and do their thing of course
and she is gorgeous she's gorgeous
she's a good good gorgeous what else we
got shout out to her and the bags under
eyes all right which cookie is that
cookie
I mean doughnut it's these maple butter
try that
okay so um 30v got into a Twitter fight
with a conservative Journal conservative
journalist you know this lady over the
song twerk she just released a music
video where basically it's just her and
a whole bunch of girls just you know
about that music video yeah so cardi B
has a new music video that you're
straight mind you like I don't know if
you're gonna dig it but so it's all
women and they what they have for the
best workers in the world you get a
hundred grand so she puts the best ones
in the video and it's a cool video
mm-hmm but basically it came out and
they're in the era of the me to movement
how exactly this empower women Hamill
asked while sharing the twerk video
leftists I am cardi B feel free to chime
in thanks I love America everybody gets
to adopt one of you but cardi B
basically said that her video means that
she could do whatever she wants say
whatever she wants wear whatever she
wants and no means no to which the
conservative journalist said I agree
with that I just don't agree with you
twerking because has a flat ass she
actually addresses that to she says
maybe I'm just hating because I can't
work yeah because you're ugly
no name a hot girl no no no I think not
I think Oh name one go no right I think
I think that there's this what she's
probably maybe saying is that you know
if you want to be taken seriously maybe
twerking your ass into the [ __ ]
camera is cardi B doesn't want me think
there's she's making she's the most
successful singer in the business well
she's being political so she's trying to
be a little bit serious cardi B is sorry
B well she was well-known for being on
Instagram and making videos about
whatever and she does tend to talk about
a lot of things like she talks about the
government shutdown he talked about
taxes before yeah you know what's that
have to do with your making a music
video of clapping her cheeks she can't
be an Apollo she's making a no she's
making a political statement and and not
in the video she's not let me see let me
see it let me see it
uh it's a music video for clapping
cheeks but the
what she does for business and her
political views to the right let me see
that video let's get let's get serious
here I'll be the judge basically to show
you guys the music video why are you
dudes why are you funny
why are you look I just spoke about the
guy so I had great legs flute out Ludo
oh I'm trying it flute out bro yeah I
appreciate working no don't try jumping
on this train now you're talking all
that [ __ ] buckle and any guy I mean
girl who works it's not the best I'm
never gonna hear it but I appreciate the
video and she's dressed like a tiger
twerk cardi beast oh man her friends
really fun doesn't do a thing for me oh
yeah she'll have a [ __ ] dude come on I
think you clearly don't care yeah they
are good-looking down look at these
asses
she's like a zebra Brian's like oh
that's gross hey it is ridiculous
ridiculously awesome it is true that if
I was a feminist I'd be like well you're
not gonna how our girls gonna be taken
seriously
oh yeah Courtney be right there yeah it
is she's hot no no no no no don't try
card attract that's a hot dude I mean
I'll say its name anyone who's
attractive he's hating on these women
that's how it goes red no that's not
fair
you can you can you know but just bring
one up well you have to be a hater and
still think this nicki minaj jealous
right
they put nicki minaj not hating on cardi
B for making this video
true true oh [ __ ] nice back flip look at
her body though look at that one in the
leopard thing
who's that leopard girl man George yeah
no the other one but once her friend
dude damn let me tell you this right now
I take this [ __ ] very seriously
new tell me this isn't entertaining I
can't stop looking at it now the girl
who won the best clapping video
she's at the end here you'll see she's
the one who won the award I don't know
now I am a little confused why they're
doing it in the dirt that's where they
lose me but she gets down in this dirt
that's by the way shooting this would
take all day they must have been tiger
yeah but their lower backs were on fire
it's a real art to torque though you
know sure is dude you're crazy if you
don't think this is the theme song in
every strip club across America when
this comes on all the girls just wow
there's always one theme song in the
strip club this is it now here comes the
real twerker Chios ham that serves a
boom ooh jeepers bro
this is not right man hey girl you win
the one who wins but I don't get why
they're in the dirt oh oh [ __ ] yeah bro
oh [ __ ] these are athletes but she's all
dirty well okay I don't need the race is
common that they're athletes I said
they're a bunch of white girls those are
athletes those are white notice color
get left kay Leslie man you coming bro
you're coming down on me for being a gay
racist and this is [ __ ] not this is
not fair well I'm more of a feminist now
that I've seen that video so thank you
Carter be shadow to cardi B know what
else we got um I've got a really creepy
one
chin seems like out of it why because
those asses were in your face yeah so
much I mean I was disapproving yeah
you're like Chris Dave who the [ __ ]
Dave what do we get
my rivetted song I've ever heard but
anyway all right so this girl was in a
vegetative state for a very long time
yes since she was three years old into a
hospital and then she's 29 years old now
and then if they found out that a male
nurse 36 year old male nurse impregnated
her sometime within the last nine-month
Cal bill know has a scene like this and
with Herman oh yeah his kids and the guy
was always raping her he and
buddy hold on but in the real life what
happens
she's vegetable state and the guy taking
care of her was having sex my male nurse
somehow snuck in and just has to image
she just gave birth suddenly and the
nurse is like what the hell is going on
here so they call the obviously the
paramedics and everything and they're
like this doesn't make any sense he's
given birth well so they found out with
DNA evidence that Sherlock what does
make sense like what she's like yeah but
imagine a girl just kind of just there
okay I bet you yeah but maybe I'll
survive that's all I know it's alive now
good I don't know if she's that good
because it was blue for a while wasn't
breathing for a while I bet you this
happens all the time
really yep and I bet you the parents of
that girl or that probably because they
have a child from that girl I mean
that's if the kids okay
if thunking oxygen is the brain of
things me that's two impregnated her
okay can we do some screening when we
have are not can you open both eyes nope
you got one lazy one can't work here
yeah I get a profile it's pretty easy to
do - now boys your eyes can't have your
work here bro why because you have one
lazy eye
you know freak out the customers yeah
this looks like guys have sex with the
customers huh yep there's no update on
the baby other than it's just it's okay
that's awesome yeah so yeah maybe the
parents are kind of well that's such a
dad yeah exactly that's what
it sucks cuz that's the dad or rapist
yeah rapist oh I know laughs eat a glass
now you to help the family had that
she's been in that vegetable state since
she was three mm state incapacitated for
a long time but then since she was a kid
yeah so she had not just family just
another kind of shot right I mean
granted your dad is one cocci but we'll
figure that out I love the child so it
says doing well
oh that's good we can't we can't always
choose how we come to this life but we
as a community can choose to love this
job I'm on board with that dude wow
that's crazy a Hacienda is in California
no Arizona Oh Hacienda health care has
assaulted any encouraging anyone with
information yeah I doubt this is
first time this has to be happening
other places so sad with a when I saw it
on Kill Bill I went that happened how's
donkeys
yeah mmm that happens all the doom I
guarantee it sure
good night you got out you got security
guards you shield I were watching those
she attractive
I don't know but it doesn't matter no
I'm just saying you know like yeah I
don't know I don't I think that guy's
just wants to I think if you've been in
a vegetative state that long your bodies
to work girl I do so so that she said
she or the family said she could respond
so she's not completely gone right so if
they talk to her say something she does
respond by moving her fingers or so
imagine that she might be unlocked in
syndrome I mean in that case she guys
all right all right all right Wow Jim
have you guys seen Jack Nicholson lately
he's been out of the public eye for a
very long time right he's been sick I
hear always think of acting yeah he's
been like he has an active life eight
years or so he retired right did he
retire I don't know what about up kid
but he just recently made an appearance
check him out he looks great yeah that's
what his son he's 81 no I'm sorry he's
he's sitting behind a jet engine
together he doesn't it's very good
that's very [ __ ] good Oh Milo by the
way he's done he's done a lot of blow
from what I understand he's still God
bless thy God he's done all Wow Wow he's
turning into real-life Joe it's his son
do come on hey you wanna know what he
does right
no dad still got them glasses on he
looks good for 81 he looks like he's
constantly eating a burden horizon
everybody's looking dude what's his
what's his butt what's his son dude the
antlers oh nothing cuz his dad's Jack
Nicholson I guess how Wow well he's on
about knowing enjoying life scroll up
what's that quotes 8 says the movie
business the greatest business but I
only want to do films that move people
films about emotions and people cool bro
hell yeah nothing sadder when it's like
Robert De Niro you know who's just like
playing these [ __ ] roles yeah or Al
Pacino he's he is top three to do it
Jack Nicholson top for sure
top dude and when they said when he was
young the parties in the women all
Francis baby sir Warren Beatty Clint
Eastwood correct they would get together
dude her buddy got dick down huh my
buddy my buddy will remain now this was
his trainer first short peers I'm gonna
go to his house and train those guys and
said it was just attic magic oh dude
pre-aids post pill Oh
ain't nobody watching what you're doing
drugs you're got rear it just [ __ ] huh
you're in [ __ ] Corvette constantly
[ __ ] Birds just dropping loads all
over this city that's right you came
king of the world and by the way back
then when a movie star was a movie star
when you were real movies large boys get
anyway there were six of you yeah okay
yeah like they talked about the reveal
of man [ __ ]
just think of it we're talking about
we're talking about like the Rolling
Stones when Mick Jagger and Keith
Richards were young they said it was the
crazy [ __ ] on the planet mmm I mean that
those guys did it all we're all boy
scouts all of us are boys honey more
what else you got
Jonah's a Jack Nicholson yes the death
of fun though you know there's a sequel
to ghostbusters but it's gonna be actual
men's noses you know the men's one I
want to Bob that to all the b2 we're
going out there no bro my god movies all
the jersey a movie Bob
because Ghostbusters is a cast of men
any man you're wrong with that being an
anti and why didn't get I did that movie
work why didn't all the women go see
that movie because it sucked right a
different movie that has women in it but
doesn't you know if to steal
Ghostbusters again that's Bill Murray
dan Aykroyd what are you talking about
who's in the new Ghostbusters it's gonna
be all just not hurt no no it's not
gonna be all with many more it's gonna
be all men so the son of the director is
actually directing the new goes Oh ramus
Ryan let's join our it's insulting is it
because the experiment did work with all
women oh okay
so instead of bridesmaids let's do
groomsmen where's our group end movie
you mean the hanging out Brendon correct
good people sullen I [ __ ] us we don't
count
yes sir Leslie Jones slams like
something trouble so it's all like [ __ ]
man no you got your shot no we try that
we tried going women first if this isn't
a man versus women thing this is the
entertainment thing that ghost was a
story was written for men yeah it's not
anti woman it's a group of dudes let's
see gonna redo ghostbusters better with
men will be huge those women ain't
ghostbusters Robinson father so during
the session dick move and I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm saying something well you do
give a [ __ ] that's why I changed some
there's nothing wrong with this yeah
well she's upset about it
and another father-son thing so Sopranos
is gonna have a film sequel but prequel
and James Gandolfini's son will play his
character toys frenum I've never seen
the episode I cannot believe I know I
really can't watch it no no I gotta
watch it I can't believe you I know do
you know how good it is I don't think
how long the to me watch Game of Thrones
no no I don't watch kids there's that
you know schema throws that worse then
there's the soprano you know here's the
problem let's watch this I go I'm not
watch I know but I need to expend
several years it's
you I know love it you know maybe I'll
start watching tonight I love Mafia [ __ ]
man it's really good you've seen an
album - I seen like the first season I
yeah you're young a [ __ ] have you seen
him no this is a little before my time
Jimmy Thrones % me - wait Kevin Barnett
died was Kevin Raye coke Gary's comedian
do we know empty
Kimbra he was the he was not really at
the Comedy Store he's a writer on the
rail and uh he's more of a new
york-based cop okay how do you down
big-time writer I'm not sure let's go
look I have no idea
does it say how I just saw the real I
found not known because not me central
put it out there something but that's
super hero rising comic in New York City
yeah you wrote on a little rail show he
did a bunch of stuff it's a bummer man
they don't tell you it's yeah drugs
suicide yeah I have no idea but usually
when they don't say that's why the
family doesn't want you the aunt sucks
what else you got that was it pretty
much it Podcast guy came out and I'm so
proud of you dick you buddy and I
appreciate that thank you for your Jack
Nicholson comment I made my pain hose
yeah you can rehash it for us oh dude
you don't let me start watching example
to mark and start recapping all the
heavy loads that are over Ollie audience
give me like dude why don't you watch
the first episode you'll probably start
to flip out I'm gonna do it tonight yeah
I'm gonna try it tonight I need a new
show to watch although puncher - baby
baby bear upon her to Netflix and also
there's a noose you're not definitely in
watch it on Amy I love my auntie show's
first 48 60 days in love those six days
in new series just started but also they
have a new thing called
the personalities of Mindy if some [ __ ]
like this and it's a girl who has like
21 different personalities a filmer they
follow her for like two years
Jesus yeah it's batshit crazy she acts
like a child checks like an adult she
goes like back in four hours
she'd be so much fun today see that so
much fun it's not it's not uh
personalities on Amy or some [ __ ] like
that per se
watch watch a scorpion
oh there it is click on the trailer look
at this crazy [ __ ] wait let's go and
look at this crazy [ __ ] like doctors a
diary a little bit more associative
Cayenne any disorder or multiple
personality disorder
this morning on the Today Show they
featured Jane's new docu-series that
premieres tonight on the A&E Network
it's called many Suns just go too many
sides of Jane [ __ ] these [ __ ]
newscasters no get ready for this click
on this nine-nine I said my name is Jane
Hart and I have di D once known as
multiple personality disorder
my person I don't always see I die I
think I'm a little more impulsive and I
found dating we're not talking about
this gene the only way out of it dude I
want her to be my financial manager to
get rid of my [ __ ] you say save like
grab [ __ ] I think yeah yeah and I
could do that too but 9 care act like
you act like a nine-year-old well that
failed I want a lollipop no experi
online I'm a nasty mag like a 24 year
old I'm 24
oh well this is a terrible bad right I'm
24 you got a whole lot of dreams I'm
attracting bats and I'm a tween hey
why'd you get Oh
you're trapped me yeah do you think
she's [ __ ] sure do not Amy only
makes real [ __ ] like you think first 48
fake you think the truth [ __ ] hater
then you know what you're a hater
watch ghostbusters with all women you
[ __ ] go do that [ __ ] you guys I'm gonna
go watch some twerking businessman the
chauvinistic episode you know I'd go
[ __ ] some donkeys you two cat you're
cool we covered a lot of stock you I'm
out he's out
all right this oh you got some dates oh
yeah come see me this coming weekend
January 31 no next week yeah January 31
there's that one that's you yes
next week Jan 31 that one front two cap
cities Austin Texas that Texas I can't
wait I love it following weekend
Jeff Jen February 7 8 9 I'm at the
American comedy club in San Diego do you
very until my black diamonds for you you
learned it bro I also wish Brian happy
birthdays birthdays this Saturday to 59
years old nope Congrats dude give us a
sign off buddy this is a fine kid we're
out
it's Brian Collins birth weekend where
to surprise him with some goodies right
Ken yeah I wish we could have fit all 60
candles we talked about that instead of
might burn up the studio there's that
and then there's also shake shop that we
got let's see what happens when Brian
arrives there's big brown and then there
oh happy birthday Brian be
[Applause]
[Music]
and Shake Shack
yeah Shake Shack - hungry yes why I warm
it up though I love you oh thank you
that's sweet of you
you guys had our plan yeah bro well
Brendan's the master planner you might
want to warm up a little bit yeah I'm
sure are they delicious so I called chin
and I asked him should I get secured
she's good they coming after 24 I didn't
know if you wanted justice is covered in
candles right is it nice guys eat - not
yet Jin said he didn't want to burn down
the building with all the candles yeah
it's been awesome